colleagues friends honored guests
welcome thank you very much for coming
tonight
it's my great pleasure to introduce
tonight's lecturer before I do that a
word of thanks and a few words about
Professor mikhail ivanovich ross stuff
Steph I start first with a warm thank
you to my colleague professor Colleen
Manasseh in the Near Eastern language
and civilizations department for
designing the beautiful poster
advertising this lecture I think many of
you have seen it Colleen is at the
moment in the middle of the western
desert of Egypt somewhere but I extend
my heartfelt thanks to her at this point
anyway Mikhail Ivanovich Rostov chef was
indeed a Titan of ancient history and
one of the Great's of 20th century
historical scholarship he taught at Yale
from 1925 until his retirement in 1944
he was one of the only ancient
historians to serve as president of the
American Historical Association he did
so in 1935 1936 he was a world authority
on Hellenistic and Roman history and
wrote widely on ancient historical
subjects particularly the field of
economic history he was an expert on the
history of South Russia and the Ukraine
as well and the art and archaeology of
dura europas most elsif began study of
the ancient world with a thesis on
pompeii followed by a master's thesis on
the scintillating subject of tax farming
in the Roman world and his PhD was on
the economic history of Rome using lead
tesserae as the primary source the
collapse of the Romanov empire and the
triumph of lemonis Bolshevism apart from
determining his view of the Roman Empire
drove him from Russia in 1918 he first
spent two years at the University of
Oxford before 1920 leaving for a chair
at the University of Wisconsin at
Madison where he was from 1920 until
1925
he describes these years of Madison as
the happiest years of his life they were
indeed very productive he wrote seven
chapters in those five years alone for
the very influential first edition of
the Cambridge ancient history in 1925
Rosoff became sterling professor of
ancient history and classical
archaeology at Yale where he publishes
two greatest works the social and
economic history of the Roman Empire in
1926 followed by the social and economic
history of the Hellenistic world in 1941
both of which have left an indelible
mark on the practices of ancient history
to this day beyond that in 1927 he
undertook and directed the Yale
excavations at the important site at
dura europas which had a profound and
long-lasting impact on the composition
of the classes department here at Yale
professor Ross Joseph's Widow Sophie
Kula ciske between the generous unto the
classics Department for the promotion of
research and archaeology and ancient
history and part of this fund is used to
support the visit of a leading figure in
ancient history each year around Rostov
Seth's birthday which we celebrate
tonight the lecture meets informally
with faculty and students and indeed Ian
will be around tomorrow morning too and
the classics department on the fourth
floor if you'd like to come and say
hello and have a chat and I believe
there's no more fitting person to serve
as the Rostov Civ lecturer than
tonight's speaker Ian Morris is
interested in understanding why the West
has dominated the earth for the last few
centuries he began his career as an
archaeologist and historian of ancient
Greece studying early texts and
excavating sites around the
Mediterranean in recent years though
he's moved toward larger scale questions
and an evolutionary approach to world
history he has written or edited an
astounding 11 books the most recent why
the West rules for now asks how
geography and Natural Resources have
shaped the distribution of wealth and
power around the world across the last
20,000 years and how they will shape our
future that book is coming out by the
way in
the fall of this year for the fall of
2010 Morris's ongoing projects include a
book on slavery and globalization a
study of Western civilization
co-authored with the historian Neil
Ferguson of Harvard University and a
volume of the forthcoming Cambridge
history of the world from 2000 through
2006 professor Morris directed Stanford
University's excavations at multiple
itso and Sicily a native Sicilian town
of the 7th and 6th centuries BC as well
as suggesting new ways of thinking about
how indigenous peoples responded to
ancient Greek colonialism the project
finds have opened up new perspectives on
the similarities and differences between
periods of imperial expansion in ancient
and modern times Ian Morris came to
Stanford from the University of Chicago
in 1995 and since then has served as
associate dean of humanities and
sciences there as chair of the classics
department as director of the social
science history Institute among many
other activities he has founded and has
directed the Stanford archaeology Center
his teaching includes classes on world
history ancient Greece slavery and
archaeology he has appeared on numerous
television shows and his prizes and
awards include fellowships from the
Guggenheim Foundation and the National
Endowment for the Humanities tonight I
think we're in for a real treat
without further ado than ladies and
gentlemen my colleague and my friend
Professor Ian Morris on what is ancient
history
okay well thank you that wonderful
introduction I hardly recognize myself
so I hope I won't embarrass myself too
much after that so what I'd like to
thank the classics department for
inviting me here to give the raw stuffs
F lecture in honor of the great man's
birthday and thank everyone especially
Jo Manning for looking after me so well
so I'm not sure what Mikhail Ivanovich
was stuff set would have made of what
I'm going to talk about tonight um Joe
took me this morning to visit the great
man's grave so that I could commune with
his spirit commune with his spirit and
see if I could pick up any vibes I
didn't pick up any vibes but I stuff
self was famous like I was saying famous
for asking big questions about the
ancient world so tonight I want to ask
what is ancient history
a basic question now I'm employed as an
ancient historian so in a way of course
it's a slightly embarrassing to stand up
here and say I don't actually know what
ancient history is but that's what I'm
going to do all the same now um I think
there's a sort of an irony too to asking
this question what is ancient history as
part of the reason that I think the
question deserves to be asked these days
is the ancient historians have been so
successful at doing what they do their
very success has made it a bit of a
problem and um well let me explain what
I mean by that if you were to go back to
the 18th century to the age before
Mikhail Ivanovich was offset to the age
of counters like this guy you're Kim
Johan you're Kim vinkle man in the late
18th century um
European thinkers at this point 1760
1770s they had a problem and as problems
went it was a pretty good problem the
problem was that they appear to be
taking over the world and they weren't
sure why this was happening
so all these theorists started to talk
about you why is this happening why are
we taking over the world and many ideas
are thrown out but one of the ones that
proved to be most successful have there
had the best legs on it the idea was
that something very peculiar happened in
Europe two-and-a-half thousand years ago
and the peculiar thing was the origin of
Greek civilized
and the Greeks the idea Ron invented a
unique dynamic and totally unparalleled
culture nothing like it in the rest of
the world being the descendants of this
Greek culture made modern Europeans
simply better than everybody else
ancient Greece was a source of a unique
European dynamism freedom creativity a
whole set of values the theory ran which
makes us superior to the rest of the
world and therefore studying ancient
Greece and Rome and this is a
contribution to civilization by
explaining what makes Europe so great
and not only does it explain what makes
Europe so great you can actually add to
the greatness of Europe by helping us
understand where our greatness came from
and then how we can build on it now in
this theory um ancient history was
basically the history that mattered the
history of Greece and Rome between
roughly 700 BCE and 300 seee about a
thousand years this was the bit of
global history that was important
now obviously very few people explicitly
go around saying stuff like that anymore
if you walk around universities saying
that kind of stuff at the very least
people will think you're a little bit
odd but that said if you look around
North American University departments
even if nobody's going around saying
this stuff anymore
we are very much living in a world an
intellectual institutional world shaped
by these ideas the numbers of
specialists at universities in North
America people working on ancient Greece
and Rome simply Dwarfs the number
working on any other parts of the
ancient world of the ancient new world
ancient China ancient India ancient Iran
ancient Africa ancient Near East any of
these fields are dwarfed by the number
of specialists work in ancient Greece
and Rome at my own University Stanford
and yeah ask any faculty member how many
people work on X at your university the
answer is always it depends how you
count and it doesn't stand for - but by
my count there's 27 of us who are
specialists on some part of antiquity 19
of the 27 work on Greece and Rome 22 of
the 27 work on some part of the
Mediterranean Basin now
if you were Johann Joachim Winckelmann
and that would probably seemed a
reasonable distribution of resources and
labor if you don't buy into the
assumptions that there's Theory brought
up in the 18th century that distribution
of resources labor does start to seem a
little bit peculiar it rests on a
particular set of assumptions about what
really matters but what ancient history
is how you define it and how we should
distribute the resources to pursue that
definition of antiquity so in a way my
question tonight is really is this the
most useful way of studying antiquity
now obviously plenty of people don't
think this is the most useful way to
study antiquity plenty of people will
say you know there's a basic unity to
humanity all over the world we evolved
together humans are the same things
wherever in the world you find them
they're the legacy of millions of years
of evolution modern Homo sapiens
involved in Africa starting around 6070
thousand years ago migrated out of
africa spread all over the world they'd
filled up most of China certainly by
forty thousand years ago Europe by
thirty-five thousand years ago the new
world by about 12,000 years ago
biological evolution of course has
continued in the last 70,000 years but
we are still basically the same
creatures wherever on the planet you
find us so taking that as our starting
point
um it's might seem a bit silly to have
this massive imbalance in the
distribution of resources for studying
the the ancient history of the world now
there are obviously there are
differences between greco-roman ancient
civilizations and other ancient
civilizations you get different scripts
and different parts of the world
different people doing their stuff
Confucius on the left here Herodotus on
the right I wanted to have Confucius and
Homer but I discovered if you go to
google image and look for Homer there
was about two hundred thousand images of
Homer Simpson and I couldn't actually
find one of the poet Homer which I'm
sure says something very profound
although I'm not quite sure what I'm
different sorts of art in different
parts of the world Joe dynasty Bruns
vessel on the left and Greek core I on
the right obvious differences between
different parts of the world and no one
would want to deny that for a moment
but there are plenty of scholars out
there outside the classics departments
and inside them too who will say that um
these differences are just twists and
wrinkles on the basic underlying
similarities in a shared global
evolutionary story if you take that
perspective ancient Greece and Rome
pretty much automatically lose their
privileged place in the store and
there's lots and lots of books you can
look at it you have to make this more
concrete this is not a new idea either
not sums a radical new thing
anthropologists have been saying this
for the best part of a century if you go
back to 802 one of the classics of an
social evolutionism morten Fried's book
the evolution of political society came
out in 1967 back in the dark days when I
was a graduate students all
archeologists read this book our Fried's
evolution of political society Greece
and Rome each crop up on three out of
the 242 pages about two and a half
percent of the pages in this book
mentioned ancient Greece and Rome if you
take one of those are the Bibles of
current world history David Christians
2004 book maps of time Greece and Rome
each crop up and 16 out of the 491 pages
in that book about 6 percent of the
pages mentioned Greece or Rome if you
take felipe fernandez armed estos recent
huge text book the world second edition
came out this year greece comes up on 25
pages and rome on 12 pages so it looks
like um greece and roma are doing better
but the book has a thousand and fifty
six pages greece and rome come up a less
than four percent of the pages in this
book that's not a lot um Beth Pollard an
ancient historian at San Diego State
wrote a very interesting article came
out in the journal classical world in
2008 and she looked at what's happened
to the teaching of greco-roman history
in high schools over the last 20-30
years and what she found is a very from
state to state but pretty much
everywhere it's been subsumed into
larger either social studies courses or
else it gets reduced to being one
example of a range of pre-modern
agrarian societies and you can study
Greece and Rome but often Greece and
Rome will be an interchangeable units
you can study Hana
instead or Maori and India or maybe the
two out of a batch of half a dozen
ancient agrarian societies people are
very rarely required in high schools to
study Greece and Rome anymore
now the bluntest statement of this is
one comes from a wonderful book by a
historian and geographer named al Crosby
published a book twenty some years ago
called ecological imperialism it's a
great book and I recommend it very
highly to everybody and I want to cite
it because it is the bluntest statement
but I think it also makes explicit what
a lot of people feel implicitly Crosby
says at one point in his book between
that era when agriculture was invented
and the time of development of the
societies that sent Columbus and other
voyages across the oceans around 1500
seee
roughly four thousand years passed
during which little of importance
happened that's all you need to know
about ancient history little of
importance happens so there the Crosby
view of things not only are Greece and
Rome a small part of antiquity
there's actually nothing much about
antiquity worth dwelling on anyway so
hence my question what is ancient
history and is it just a very very tiny
thing or is it the secret to
understanding the whole planet now I'm
to set up the talk and to keep it
reasonably short at least I thought it
would try to simplify the theories down
to like three competing answers to the
question of what is ancient history
I'm sure you can think of other possible
answers too but this I found a useful
organization the first of these what
I'll call the standard model and that
there was a unique particularly Greek
but greco-roman achievement which was
developed and then spread around the
ancient Mediterranean world by the Roman
Empire passed on from the Roman Empire
until it reached the pinnacle of
civilization in the modern West here we
have the pinnacle of civilization this
was taken in the town I was born in in
the month I was born the hospital I was
born in is just off the picture to the
left now because of the level of
pollution in stoke-on-trent you can't
tell what time of day this is but I like
to tell myself this was taken as I was
being being born into this world which
may or may not be true pinnacle of
civilization but of course I just
here is the pinnacle of civilization ok
so that's the first Theory the standard
mark
second simplified theory the global
model as I'll call it Greece and Rome
are simply examples of agrarian empires
and that's all there is to say about it
third model Crosby model nothing really
happened in ancient history so let's
stop now and go straight to the
reception okay so what I want to do is
just talk about these three theories and
I want to say before I launch into this
um my my goal in doing this is not to
try to debunk greco-roman history like
when I was a graduate student it was
very fashionable for a while for people
doing greco-roman history to go around
saying what nonsense Greek and Roman
history was the implication being of
course that we are all so sophisticated
that we've risen above our our moronic
peers and can see the world better and
that is is not what I'm trying to do
here but I think though that something
is happening to our field real and
important changes are underway and Beth
Pollard's article makes that very very
clear whether we like it or not our
field is changing more rapidly now than
it's any time since the late 18th
century and we have the choice of
getting out in front of this and
understanding it and taking leadership
in these changes or not and that I think
is the real issue do we want to be
leading what happens to our field or do
we want it to be driven by other people
so okay these three simplified
representations of theories out there
about what ancient history might be now
I think the only way you can possibly
adjudicate between three theories like
this is comparatively if we start off
just by sort of looking very general
terms what was happening across ancient
Eurasia in say the first millennium BCE
we see some pretty interesting patterns
some striking similarities as well as
differences one thing that we see in the
area on this map between the thick black
lines marking to the where the major
ancient old-world civilizations were
pretty much everywhere between the thick
black lines in the first millennium BCE
population roughly doubles and it varies
around the doubling figure but somewhere
in that order roughly doubles striking
similarities pretty much everywhere not
surprisingly we see agricultural
intensification going on and more
irrigation more manuring more use of
ploughs here a Greek example in Chinese
on this picture we see much more
intensive agriculture altogether extreme
example of course the Roman aqueducts
and here you see one marching mile after
mile across the desert of what's now
Tunisia we see the spread of iron
technology across this whole area here
iron tools I'm not sure why I put this
slide in except that I have it I'm sure
you know what iron tools look like we
see the spread of iron technology in the
level of use of iron all across this
area we see the spread of things like
water mill say alternative sources of
power again all across this van's
extreme example once again from the
western end and this is just a couple of
reconstruction drawings of the famous
barber gal water mill in rome at full
power this would give you roughly the
same energy output as to Model T Fords
running at full power and through an
agrarian society that's a lot of energy
output but similar but less ambitious
water mills you'll find all across this
area of Eurasia um see the spread of
writing or all across Eurasia more
intensive use of it new forms of it
again there's Western examples here the
spread of the Greek alphabet er the
green we guys forgot brown and darker
brown the way the slide is coming out
the lighter brown areas on the map up at
the left show you where the Greeks are
colonizing darker brown where the
Phoenicians colonize down at the bottom
left a famous example one of the
earliest examples of the Greek alphabet
around 750 BCE very very clearly derived
from the Phoenician script before it
this alphabet spreads out around the
Mediterranean basin there's a huge
spread in writing in China after about
600 BCE rapid that in India after about
500 rapid expansion of trade the use of
coinage across all of these areas in the
first millennium BCE steady growth in
the size of cities all across this band
of Eurasia across the first millenium
say around a thousand BCE
the biggest city at the western end of
Eurasia is probably Sousa 25,000 people
maybe the eastern end is probably the
city of Qi maybe about 35,000 people by
the end of the 1st millennium BC you've
got probably half a million people in
Chiang gone in China 300,000 apps in
Alexandria probably a million in the
city of Rome here Mussolini's famous and
model of the city of Rome enormous
growth in cities all across this pound
and enormous increase in armies in their
size and power at the western end of
Eurasia in Assyria we see the
replacement of chariots by cavalry by
about 800 BCE the introduction of mass
infantry armies with iron weapons over
the next century or so here more
Assyrians getting very angry with each
other but I say about 250 BCE the romans
and carthaginians can mobilize several
hundred thousand troops that ago and i
didn't have any good Punic Wars slide so
this is slightly later but your Romans
doing what Romans are best known for
here similar sort of things going on the
eastern end of Eurasia cavalry replacing
chariots and here the famous chariot
from the chin first emperor's tomb by
600 BCE cavalry more or less replaced
chariots mass infantry armies by 500 BCE
armies hundreds of thousands strong by
250 BCE again and here we've got the
former first family visiting the former
first emperors two famous terracotta
army here States Reorganisation going on
all across this band of societies the
growth of bureaucracy all across this
band of societies the remarkable set of
similarities across the complex
societies the first millennium BCE
Eurasia now okay the reason I launched
into that little soliloquy there about
similarities across Eurasia is to give
an example though of some of the
difficulties that are thinking about
these kinds of similarities and
differences like anybody could come up
here and stand here and blather on for
50 minutes about similarities or I can
give you a list of differences and this
will be very easy to do the problem with
this is it's a very messy highly
subjective kind of process and when I
say subjective what I mean specifically
is it's that riddled with assumptions
that are difficult to make explicit so
if I stand up here rattle off this list
of similarities it'd be very different
for very difficult for a rival historian
who didn't agree with me to come and pin
me down on why some things are being
chosen why not others so um because of
that
what I've been trying to do the last few
years been thinking about this problem
for a little while now and it seemed to
me that the way to make some progress
with these comparisons and looking for
what this how important are the
similarities the way to make some
progress would be to reduce the process
of comparisons to something but simpler
and more direct and more explicit not
necessarily more objective but more
explicit in that the assumptions have to
be spelled out a bit more to make it
easier for us to have the arguments
instead of arguing endlessly over what
the assumptions should be and to me it
seemed that the obvious way to do this
was by finding something we could
measure I mean any of you who've been
had the unfortunate experience of
reading any of my work will know I tend
to assume this about most problems you
find something to measure you begin to
force people to confront each other on
the same issues so I decided one useful
thing to measure and the different
societies across eurasia in the ancient
period would be their levels of social
development and then we can compare
these and ask ourselves is there
something really distinctive about
Western Eurasia like the standard model
says are the differences across this
area really very small the way the more
global model says or is the whole thing
boring and pointless the way the Crosby
model says so what I mean when I say
Social development's to think it's
important to be I'm explicit about these
things and I should say one of my pet
hatreds is people who read PowerPoint
slides out but this is now what I'm
about to do and what I mean by social
development is basically society's
ability to get things done and so to
make it a bit more formalized the the
bundle of technological subsistence
organizational and cultural
accomplishments through which people
feed clothe house and reproduce
themselves explain the world around them
resolve disputes within their
communities extend their power at the
expense of other communities and defend
themselves against others attempts to
extend their power so a bit of a
mouthful but I want you to get it all
into one sentence I thought that was
sound better um social development it's
basically a group's ability to master
its physical and intellectual
environment and in principle at least
this is the sort of thing that ought to
be measurable and comparable at
comparable across time and space and it
allow us to put the discussion on a more
solid
now um social development is obviously
not the only thing you can look at if
you want to try to be a bit more
explicit about the comparisons but I
found it's a very useful way to sort of
crack into this question to open things
up to get into so um in order to just
come up with some kind of measurements
of social development what I decided to
do was to boil it down into four traits
that I think we can look at which I
think more or less cover the range of
what I'm talking about in this
definition here and the four traits I
settled on which I chose partly for
their ability to cover what we're
talking about partly for them being
things that we can at least up to a
point measure of it the four traits were
energy capture by which I mean how much
energy per capita is consumed by people
each day in different parts of the world
at different times levels of
organization and for that I chose a like
a lot of social scientists do the proxy
variable of urbanization I just took
this size of the biggest city in each
part of the world at different times as
just a rough guide to how much
organization is out there their
information technology I they the which
from most of the periods means the
techniques of literacy of storing
information and distributing it how many
people are able to read and write and
send things around and then there
war-making capacity which again I think
within very rough limits can be measured
and so to to play my little game with
these variables I assigned a maximum up
to 250 points for each variable so if
the total possible score the thousand
points on my development scale now this
enormous room as I'm sure you can
imagine for arguments between
specialists over whether it's possible
to score these things how you actually
do the scoring what the number should be
but that said I love that kind of stuff
that's my idea of fun is arguing with
people about that and within certain
limits I think we can pull together the
archaeological and textual evidence and
very roughly measure these things across
time now this sort of research obviously
it's what one of my colleagues at
Stanford likes to call chainsaw arts
it's not like being Rembrandt or
something yay all the little details
exactly right if you ask me are your
development scores right the answer is
No
everything I'm about to tell you is
wrong but that doesn't matter because
the real question is how long are they
are they wrung enough that it throws
everything off or are they just wrung
enough that we can sort of live with in
live with the problems and the
inaccuracies are they within our
tolerances for error for the kind of
problems are trying to solve now I will
happily bore you with all the details if
you asked but I won't intentionally set
out to bore you if I'm boring you that's
accidental and so but if you are
interested all these details I'm happy
to blather on a great length at the end
of this thing but basically and it seems
to me there are other things you could
try to measure there are other ways you
can measure these from the ways that I'm
trying to measure them but pretty much
any way of measuring that stays close to
mainstream scholarly opinion actually
produces more or less the same results
at the end of the day there's always
going to be differences but not enormous
ones okay final thing I want to say in
this part of the talk if we go back to
the end of the Ice Age they looked about
fifteen thousand years ago and look at
the world fifteen thousand years ago
there's half a dozen places around the
world where more complex societies begin
to develop and they're marked on this
map and over the last few years I've
been looking at these regions trying to
trace the development of complex
societies out of them and its expansion
geographically across the last fifteen
thousand years but an interesting thing
struck me that across almost the whole
of the last fifteen thousand years the
societies with the highest social
development scores always came from one
of two of the original half dozen
regions which are the ones marked as the
hilly flanks and the yellow Yangtze
valleys on this map the area that began
in the heli flanks this expanded outward
incorporated the ancient Mediterranean
Greek and Roman civilizations ended up
incorporating modern Europe the Americas
following what I think is common sense
I'm going to call that the western area
since it begins at the western end of
Eurasia the other area the yellow
Yangtze valleys area dad of course
expands outward incorporates Korea Japan
partially at least Southeast Asia I'm
gonna call that the eastern area for
that again what I think is a very good
reason that it's at the eastern end of
raesha okay so um the reason I tell you
that to keep the the talk manageable to
finish it up reasonably on time what I'm
gonna do in the rest of my time is just
compare these two regional traditions
across the last 15 thousand years I
think I can narrow my what is ancient
history question down so just a two way
comparison here there's more we could do
we could make it more subtle and nuanced
for the to way comparison I think gets
to the basic points um the question
becomes was Western ancient history
really as distinct from Eastern ancient
history as the standard model the
greco-roman standard model would assume
or was Western ancient history really a
similar to Eastern ancient history as
the global model would assume or is the
whole thing really as boring and
pointless as the Crosby model would
assume so okay now that's enough
preamble or you may be saying at this
point that's too much preamble
what do we actually get if we do all
these things I'm going on about well
this is what we get this is my graph now
you look at this graph and you may be
thinking that is a rather disappointing
graph particularly because the lines are
supposed to be more different colors and
long red and blue they're kind of blue
and purple but what can what can you do
um rather disappointing graph it's hard
to see very much on this graph unless
your eyesight is a whole lot better than
mine which because it may well be um
hard to see very much on this graph and
that though I think tells us to quite
interesting things right away I think
that's the first thing that you do see
on this graph is that the lines of the
eastern and western lines are rather
hard to distinguish on this graph now
that I think is a problem for the
standard model it seems to me the
standard model implies that the Western
and Eastern scores really should be more
different especially in the period
between about a thousand BCE and 500 CE
II second thing I think you see if the
lines are more or less flat along the
bottom of the graph until about two
hundred years ago they take a ninety
degree turn and shoot almost straight up
now that seems to be to me to be most
consistent with the Crossley model that
basically nothing happened nothing
interesting happened until the last
couple hundred years then suddenly
everything happens
now um the problem is the the the second
of these points and the abrupt 90-degree
turn around 200 years ago that largely
explains the first of these points you
can see that the the sort of the darker
line zips way of way of over 900 points
the western score for the year 2000 C II
in order to get a 900 point score on
this graph we have to compress
everything else down into the very very
bottom of the graph the lines look very
similar through most of the history of
the world since the end of the Ice Age
but actually they're not
now this next graph this shows you
exactly the same data but the graph
stops in the year 1900 instead of the
year 2000 so we only have to go up to
180 points instead of the thousand
points and here you can see there's a
lot of difference between the here the
colors came out better as well this one
between the blue line for the Western
scores and the red line for the Eastern
scores we see a number of things I think
on this got a number of interesting
things one is that the Western Eastern
scores are clearly not the same
um the Western score has been slightly
higher than the Eastern score ever since
the end of the eye or almost ever since
the end of the Ice Age ninety percent of
the time since the end of the Ice Age
the Western score has been higher but
what we also see is is rather difficult
to say that's because of anything
special about Greece and Rome the
Western school had been higher for
thousands of years before the period we
conventionally call greco-roman ancient
history so okay what else do we see here
couple of obvious things I think leap
out from this graph one is the generally
upward trend in the scores and not only
are they rising but the rate at which
they're rising is accelerating as you
move through time from left to right
another thing we see is that the the
upward trend in scores is not uniform
there's big disruptions in these scores
I think these are very very important ok
one more graph now stop with the graphs
for a little while this graph same data
once again but now just see what we
would normally call I think the
canonical ancient period about a
thousand BCE to 600 CE and and the
Western Eastern scores again the western
one in blue the eastern one in red what
I think we see on this graph only zero
in and I ain't
period is that we can more or less
divided into two phases the first is the
first millennium BCE when in East and
West alike the social development scores
are rising sometime in the early first
millennium CE II or ad or whatever you
choose to call it um the scores in both
areas start falling the dropping in both
areas to roughly the earth 400 so what I
want to do now for the remainder of my
time is just talk about a little bit
about these trends and these sort of two
phases the upward phase BCE and the
downward phase in the first century CE
now the upward trend in the first
millennium BCE I think there are four
important things going on the drive
social development upward in both the
eastern and the western ends of Eurasia
in the first millennium BCE the first of
these is what I'm calling state
restructuring at the beginning of the
first millennium BCE the states of both
ends of Eurasia or what we might call
low end states or mafia states some
people will sometimes call them you tend
to had a king who sits on the top of
society who's surrounded by a group of
parasitic rats and the King says the
aristocrats bring me troops and they are
ahsoka let's bring the troops
everybody goes off and they plunder
somebody and then they share out the
plunder between them very cheap to run a
state like this the King doesn't need
much in the way of revenue flows because
he doesn't get much revenue coming in
either because he shares it all ours now
I'm during the first millennium BCE all
across Eurasia in the complex societies
there's a shift from the low-end model
toward a high-end model where you get
rulers who run bigger than bigger
bureaucracies who tax their states more
and more efficiently who have salaried
armies on the on the King's own payroll
this trend accelerates in the western
end of Eurasia and this character here
tiglath-pileser the third of Assyria is
the figure normally associated with the
take-off of this trend in Eastern you're
a very much sixth fifth fourth centuries
BCE in China and the spring and autumn
and warring States Period by the late
1st millennium the fascinating
similarities between the Roman Empire
the Qin and Han empires in the eastern
end of Eurasia Mauryan Empire in India
striking similarities by the 3rd 2nd
centuries BCE
now in this part of the story the state
restructuring ancient Greece is really
very unimportant in this story ancient
Greek city-states were just not very
powerful Rome on the other hand is a
very important part of the story Rome is
arguably the great ancient empire okay
second of my four things I'm
intellectual restructuring back in the
1940s very famous guy german philosopher
named Karl Jasper's I'm wrestling with
his sense of moral crisis at the end of
the Second World War
Jasper's suggested that the first
millennium BCE was what he called the
axial age of world history by which he
meant it was the axis around the entire
history around which the entire history
of the world turned and yeah Spurs that
is a resounding phrase he said man as we
know him today came into being in the
axial age and then what he meant by that
it's always a bit difficult to drag out
from the Oscars what he's actually
saying but what he meant by that seems
to be that um the first millennium BCE
saw a broad shift away from older ideas
that society was founded on some kind of
pact between a god-like ruler and
supernatural powers of which of course I
was normally taken as the extreme
example of either the Pharaohs of the
Old Kingdom Egypt Middle Kingdom Egypt
perhaps a shift away from that toward
I'm some kind of individual
transcendence within a disenchanted
world an idea that nobody really has
contact with the divine sphere it's up
to us our selves to save ourselves we
see different versions of this and going
on all the way from China through India
through Iran and Palestine to the
ancient Greek world
now obviously Confucius is not the same
thing as Plato everybody knows this but
all across this area in especially the
middle of the first millennium you see
societies mapping out very similar
spaces for debates in South Asia you get
to buddhism and jainism in china get it
with Confucianism and Daoism in western
Eurasia you you get in the Hebrew Bible
Greek philosophy and a lot lots of more
variants as well they are all intensely
riven by internal debates about how you
transfer
this world in all of these areas you'll
get some people are very very mystical
about it so like in the West you get
Parmenides in the east you get some
strands of Taoism you'll get some people
are very empirical and practical so in
the West you get characters like
Aristotle in the East you get you have
some strands of Confucianism you get
some very populist versions of it you
get Protagoras in Greece moat say in
China you get some very authoritarian
versions of it legalism in China some
bits of Plato in the West you get some
extremely relativist versions of it like
say Jainism in India
Taoism in some parts of Taoism in China
the nature culture debate in ancient
Greece and all of these debates similar
debates going on across the old world at
roughly the same time now Greece of
course is very important in this part of
the story Greek democracy is pretty much
a unique solution to how you live in a
world without godlike rulers Greek
philosophy is pretty much a unique
response because it's very much
responding to the unique Greek democracy
um but having said that even the Greek
versions of these debates they're very
much arguments within the broader range
of debates we get across the whole of
the old world in all of these places the
idea is a very new compared to second
millennium BCE ideas in all of them the
first millennium BCE is the age of the
classics everywhere from Greece to China
this is when the classics are written
the timeless literature that defined the
intellectual terrain for billions of
people for the next 2,000 plus years one
conclusion we might draw from that is
that if saying that ancient history is
greco-roman history if we think that's
not the way to go probably saying that
classics is Greek and Roman literature
is not the way to go either so okay so
all across this area
these sorts of intellectual ferments are
going on by the end of the first
millennium BCE all across this area the
restructured States are coming to terms
with the intellectual restructuring the
Han Dynasty
finds room for a version of Confucianism
and Confucianism in fact ends up
becoming a kind of state ideology almost
and in India the great warrior king
ashoka converts to buddhism
2:57 BCE he does this because he's
appalled appalling genuinely appalled at
the slaughter he himself has caused in
his wars of conquest he converts the
Buddhism in such a way that he doesn't
have to give up waging war on people
very clever conversion at the western
end of Eurasia Roman rulers find ways to
adapt Greek philosophy to their own ends
Marcus Aurelius can grow a Greek beard
fight Germans all day go back to his
tent invite the meditations all night
they all bends um the Axial Age
philosophy to their own end as by the
early first millennium CE II okay third
of my big themes in the first millennium
BCE is the geographical expansion of the
cause all across Eurasia we see the
growth of cities two states two empires
across the first millennium BCE this is
something I've been very interested in
myself like Jo mentioned between 2000
and 2006 I directed an excavation at a
little type of monte paulo toward the
western end of sicily a little
indigenous Sicilian site and we went
there to see what happened to indigenous
Sicilian society when Greek and
Phoenicians colonists settled along the
coasts of the island within sight of the
place where we were digging this is a
view out to the west from the the top of
the hill we were digging on out toward
the Greek to the finish and colony of
Murcia you can see off in the far
distance so we went there to try to find
out what happens to these native
societies when the colonists come out
we've dug up all kinds of cool stuff
here we are digging back in 2001 on the
top of the hill we dug up there the main
thing we focused on was a circular
indigenous sanctuary at the top of the
hill we found goodies from all over the
Mediterranean base and top left we've
got a what people were called East Greek
be to cut from about 575 BCE bottom left
is an imitation of an Egyptian scarab
from around 600 BCE bottom right is a
local tradition bronze figurine from
about 600 top right is a Punic Steely
from about 300 BCE so all kinds of
goodies we're very happy with the the
the plunder that we pulled in but what
we realized on increasingly dawned on us
as we were doing this project was that
the Greek and Phoenician expansion
across the Mediterranean Basin
um well there's a lot of interesting and
unique stuff about it in many ways it's
just another version of the expansion
out of a core area into peripheries but
you can see going on since the end of
the Ice Age we see these processes going
on simultaneously in the first
millennium BCE all across western
Eurasia South Asia eastern Eurasia
particularly large-scale in all of these
places across the first millennium BCE
everywhere you look you're looking at a
combination of migration out from the
core an indigenous copying of what's
going on within the core all of the
historiography and all of these
expansions is always about exactly the
same question is it driven by
colonization or indigenous developments
and the answer in every single case is
is yes a bit of both and we spent seven
seasons digging up this site and came to
the conclusion yes it's a bit of both to
the ancient Mediterranean so now the
Greeks are an important part of the
story of the geographical expansion of
the core the Romans an even more
important part of the story the the
colonization process helped draw the
Mediterranean basin into a single core
area the Roman Empire did the same much
as was going on in eastern Asia at
exactly the same time okay finally my
four topics economic growth since the
1970s Roman historians have demonstrated
I think very convincingly rising levels
of consumption of per capita energy
capture across the first millennium BCE
and the last few years a number of Greek
historians have gotten interested in
doing the same kind of thing to economic
growth was the core topic of a book that
I edited with my colleagues Walter shy
del and Richard sallow a couple years
ago the Cambridge economic history of
the greco-roman world we decided and it
should actually been called the Stanford
economic history since Walter and
Richard both came out to Stanford or
perhaps even the Chicago economic
history because we'd all been at Chicago
has had your very own Joe Manning who's
a contributor to the volume and Peter
Bedford from Union College was here
tonight another contributed the volume
also been in Chicago but the core idea
in this book was that one of the things
that's completely dropped out of ancient
economic history is any discussion of
economic
growth even though this is the core
thing that economic historians of other
periods will tend to say is the most
important so by my estimates were
working on the Greek material by 300 BCE
the typical Greeks level of consumption
was about 50 percent higher than it had
been 500 years earlier which is trivial
by modern standards enormous by premark
the standards the numbers are a bit less
clear in eastern Asia we're less
quantitative work has been done but
we're dealing with very very similar
patterns that much is clear
so okay first millennium BCE
characterised in east and west alike by
four processes state restructuring
intellectual restructuring expansion of
the core and economic growth the idea of
a unique Greco Roman history wildly
different from the rest of the world
I think begins to look less convincing
once you put in this kind of framework
okay next thing I want to say a couple
of words about that was talking about
this of upward slope on this graph the
first millennium BCE now I just want to
quickly say something like the downward
part of it there the early first
millennium CE sometime in the first
couple of centuries CE II social
development starts falling in eastern
and western Eurasia and in South Asia
too for that matter we get the fall of
the Roman and the Han empires of all
kinds of stuff happening we've got some
excellent quantitative evidence from
Western Eurasia and this is a graph I
put together from other people's work
showing you in red and the numbers of
Roman shipwrecks in the Mediterranean
I've normally taken as a proxy for the
levels of trade in blue and the levels
of lead pollution in Spanish bugs which
is a pretty good proxy for certain kinds
of industrial production and as you can
see the lines march up and down and
together rather striking correlation and
there's other variables we could have
thrown in a number of animal bones a
number of monumental buildings put up
the number of inscriptions preserved
they don't match on perfectly but the
basic shape of all these curves is much
the same now I'm a lot of historiography
in the last 30 years I think as somewhat
tended to obscure what's happening on
the right hand side of this graph
there's been a reaction against the old
decline and fall models
- what see what happens in something in
the western part of Eurasia in the early
first millennium CE II as a
transformation rather than the old
Gibbon decline fall kinda model and
there's a lot to be said for the
transformation the cultural
transformation model but it has obscured
adding some very very basic economic and
political realities but social
development does tumble dramatically in
both east and west in the first few
centuries CE II by 500 CE also the the
last thing I want to say about this
graph a great east-west divergence
begins up till that point up to the 6th
century CE Western social development
was always higher than Eastern social
development in the 6th century though
Chinese are creating a new agricultural
frontier in southern China they reunite
the Empire in 589 in the West we don't
get anything like that there's a series
of attempts to recreate a great Empire
Justinian the Arab conquest Charlemagne
but no success in doing it West and
social development continues tumbling
into the 8th century for several
centuries thereafter Eastern social
development is higher than Western now
ok so a lot more could be said uh
obviously um but I'm gonna wrap up now
with some quick thoughts going back to
the three theories that I started from
the three answers to the question what
is ancient history um having now talked
a little bit about the work I've been
doing the last couple of years what does
this mean for an answer to this question
okay the standard theory the standard
model Greece and Rome are unique and we
should reserve the name of ancient
history basically for greco-roman
history well this theory I think is
fairly misleading the greco-roman world
has a lot in common with other ancient
civilizations Western social development
closely tracks East and Social
Development State restructuring
intellectual restructuring geographical
expansion economic expansion all of
these are going on all across the band
of complex societies across Eurasia in
the first millennium BCE all across this
band of complex societies they're major
disruptions at the beginning early to
mid 1st millennium CE II tumbling social
development for several centuries
thereafter I think it's hard to claim
that what happened in the mid
Turanian basin was so different from
what happened in the rest of the world
that we should reserve the name of
ancient history for Greek and Roman
history okay
second theory that the global model this
I think is also fairly misleading
not all agrarian imperial societies are
the same Western social development
Rises extremely high by the end of the
1st millennium BCE it reaches a level at
that point that is never surpassed until
the 18th century
I'm excited there's a ceiling my
suspicion is there's a ceiling beyond
which agrarian societies cannot go and
in the Roman Empire people at the
western end of Eurasia were probably
pressing against that ceiling in Eastern
Europe certainly I think by the 11th and
12th century the time of the Song
Dynasty China is pressing against the
same ceiling but there is something
distinctive about the Mediterranean
Basin in antiquity something that does
make it deserve special attention it
develops I think as far as an agrarian
society is able to go just subsuming it
into a larger category of pre-modern
agrarian civilizations I don't think
that's a very sensible strategy for
historians ok third model under the
Crosby model basically the whole thing
is incredibly dull don't waste your time
on it I think that this deserves the
same response that it's just rather
misleading to say that nothing happened
between well as he would say between
2500 BCE and 1500 C there is a sense in
which you can say that and what we got
here to last graphs tough to hit you
with the final graphs here up at the top
is my data once again I'm showing you
the whole page from 2500 BCE to the year
2000 these that hold the whole thing
judge from the perspective the year 2000
you say yes there is something to what
Crosby says it's very hard to see
anything much happening on that top
graph before about 1800 the bottom graph
shows you my data once again but
stopping this time of the year 1500
Crosby's period Crosby says between 2500
BCE and 1500 C
basically nothing of significance
happens well I think it's very hard to
take that position if you look at this
bottom graph an awful lot of stuff
happens in this period in particular
striking thing social development in
western Eurasia is higher in the year 49
BCE when Caesar crosses the Rubicon then
it's going to be in 1492 when Columbus
crosses the Atlantic I don't see how we
can really say that the Crosby model is
the answer to to what is ancient history
so okay now back then to the opening
question what is ancient history I think
as I think will probably be fairly clear
by now ancient history should not be
just Greece and Rome between 700 BCE and
300 C I'm saying a book I admire greatly
Moses Finley's the ancient economy the
ancient economy is just about Greece and
Rome between 700 BCE and 300 C II it's a
wonderful book but the title is utterly
misleading however spectacular the
legacy of ancient Greece and Rome this
is not ancient history I think we have
to include that ancient history is a
global story starting in western Eurasia
around 5000 BCE somewhat later elsewhere
social development starts rising at an
accelerating rate for most of the
world's major civilizations the last few
millennia BCE is a time of expansion and
restructuring it's the age of the
classics especially the first millennium
BCE and its biggest and most vigorous in
western Eurasia rises by the 1st century
BCE to Heights that won't be surpassed
until the 18th century
then that's slightly varying dates but
clustered in the early first millennium
CE II all the major civilizations hit a
ceiling they stagnate they begin
declining ancient history I would say is
the story of this first great phase of
expansion and restructuring societies
developing as far as is possible in
agrarian regimes and ending in crises in
the early first millennium CE II world
history then heads up in a distinctively
different direction than medieval phase
when the East takes the lead song China
returns to Roman levels by the 11th
century but no one
they would surpass the levels of social
development we see in ancient Rome
the lung Middle Ages I would say is
about there straining against the limits
of agrarian society by people who are
very aware of this golden age and the
past you get this all across Eurasia
ending in the 18th century with a with a
breakthrough and modern history is about
the world that fossil fuels made so so
the standard theory I would say that we
can't understand Western Eurasia without
this global perspective so the
globalists I would say that Western
Eurasia was distinctive in the ancient
period and to Crosby I would say ancient
history is important it's the bridge
between the prehistoric and modern
worlds we can't understand prehistory
all modern times I think without the
ancient period in between and that's
what ancient history is so thank you
very much for listening